You may have seen an electronic key that
is opened using an RFID tag that's
inside of an access badge. But what if
you need access to a room and there
aren't access badges available? In that
situation, you might be assigned a key
fob. This is a piece of plastic
connected to a keychain that also has an
RFID tag inside of it and effectively
works very similar to an access badge.
Functionally, you would use a key fob.
Exactly the same way as an access badge.
You would move the key fob close to the
sensor. It will read the RFID tag and
then determine if you are allowed or
denied access through that door. Here's
a closer view of the key fobs. They're
usually attached to a keychain, which
makes it very easy to find them if you
ever need to gain access through that
door. Many access badges also include a
bit of storage, which allows you to keep
a certificate on that access badge. This
is a cryptographic certificate that has
been digitally signed, which means that
we can verify the person holding that
access badge containing that certificate
really is that person. Often this badge
is used in conjunction with other types
of authentication factors. So you would
scan your badge which effectively then
scans the certificate inside of the
badge. And then it's very common to use
some other type of authentication such
as a personal identification number or
biometric to confirm that that
certificate is matched with that
physical person. Sometimes this uses an
integrated reader that might be inside
of a laptop or inside of a badge reader
or you might use an external reader like
the one you see connected via USB. If
you're going to integrate this into a
laptop, you need to purchase a laptop
that has that badge reader built into
the laptop itself. And if you need to
log into the laptop, you have to slide
in your card and then provide the
additional authentication to gain access
to that
system. Instead of having a separate
badge or a separate set of physical
keys, we're now moving a lot of our keys
into our mobile phones. This is a mobile
digital key and the key itself is
integrated into the technologies of your
mobile phone. These days, we're seeing
more and more uses of mobile digital
keys. There are many cars that allow you
to start the car or unlock the doors
with the keys that are on your phone. If
you visit a hotel or have a relatively
new office, you may be able to unlock
doors with your phone. And you might
even be able to lock or unlock the doors
that you have at home using a mobile
digital key that's on your phone.
Because this is something that is on
your phone, there are additional
authentication factors that make this
digital key more secure. For example,
you need to unlock your phone to gain
access to use the mobile digital key.
And that unlocking process is
effectively the additional
authentication. But there may be times
when you don't have access to an
electronic lock. It might be too
expensive to install some type of
electronic access. or you may need
access to a room that should never be
locked electronically. You should always
have a physical lock available in case
you happen to lose power. These physical
keys are often kept in a single cabinet
and there's someone responsible for
checking out the key and checking it
back in again. It's not unusual for you
to have to provide identification. They
take your license and put it into the
cabinet while you're using the key, and
you have to return the key to get your
identification back. Here's one of these
cabinets that have all of these keys
inside for the different doors. You can
see that they each have numbers so that
you're able to check out the appropriate
key for the access that you need. And
this is where you might leave your ID so
that when you return the key, you can
also retrieve your
ID. One of the best ways to physically
ensure that the person who is
authenticating really is that person is
by using biometrics. Biometrics uses
some type of physical part of your
person, turns that into a digital key,
and stores that information for later
reference. For example, you can scan
aspects of your fingerprint to create a
digital representation of your
fingerprint. The system isn't storing a
picture of your actual fingerprint. It's
creating a mathematical model of your
fingerprint, and that becomes the key.
This makes it very easy to tie back a
specific fingerprint to a specific
person. And it also makes it very
difficult to change that or fool it in
some way. Since fingerprints are
relatively unique, it would be unusual
for someone to have exactly the same
fingerprint as someone else. Not every
form or implementation of biometrics is
as secure as any other. So, you may want
to look at the type of scanners you're
using for biometrics or the way that
you're implementing biometrics in order
to make sure that it is as secure as
possible. One of the most accurate forms
of biometrics is a retina scanner. A
retina scanner looks at the capillaries
that are in the back of your eye. This
is a unique characteristic between
individuals and it's one of the best
biometric measurements that you can use.
Another type of biometric security would
be a fingerprint scanner. We've seen
these on phones, on laptops, and even to
access different doors. And it's a great
way to provide biometrics using
something that's very easy to gain
access to your fingers. Another type of
biometric measurement uses your entire
palm with a palm print scanner. This
measures the size and the shape of your
hand to create that biometric
authentication.
If you own a mobile phone, you've
probably used facial recognition
technology or FRT to be able to use your
face to unlock your phone. This uses a
laser dot projector which looks at many
different points of your face to create
a 3D facial map. This uses a 3D model of
your face to create that biometric key.
And once that's stored, you can apply
that facial recognition technology to
anywhere where you may need to be
authenticated. This might be on your
phone or it might be the door of the
data center. This is another relatively
secure method of biometrics because we
found that there is about a 1 in 1
million false acceptance rate which is a
very strong biometric
measurement. Another biometric
measurement that you might still see
being used is voice recognition
technology. This uses your voice to
identify yourself and it's usually
trained by speaking a number of
different phrases into the scanning
device. Your style and method of
speaking is stored in a biometric form
and that is referenced again when you
use your voice to gain access to a
system. During the verification process,
you're commonly using a different set of
phrases than the ones that were used to
train with. But because you've created
this model of your voice, the voice
recognition technology can determine
whether that's you speaking or someone
else. Although voice recognition is
something that you might still run into,
it is not the strongest biometric
security that you'll find. And it's very
common to see this combined with other
factors of authentication. We also have
to keep in mind that our voice can
change depending on our health and
sometimes you may not be able to use
your voice to authenticate.
One of the best physical security tools,
and one that is often overlooked, is the
lighting that we use. As it gets darker
in an area, it becomes less secure. So,
having more lights tends to make an area
much more secure. It also makes it
easier for our other security tools to
be able to work properly. So, when we
have more lights, we're able to get
better images from the cameras that
we're using for security. There's many
different styles of lights and many
different ways to illuminate different
areas. And if your focus is on video
surveillance, you may need enough light
to be able to read license tags that are
on a car or be able to see faces so that
you can do facial recognition. And if
you're walking into a secure building,
you're probably going through a metal
detector or what's technically known as
a magnetometer. This is a passive
scanning process. You simply walk
through this particular piece of
equipment and it will be able to
identify if there's any metal on your
person. This obviously won't be able to
catch anything that is not metal. For
example, if you're carrying a weapon
that is ceramic, you won't be able to
identify that using a magnetometer.